- [Robin] From the belly of
production, there's a hallway
that leads into the studio.
I liken it to the pathway
that players walk through
to get out on to the field.
That live element is never lost on us.
You're hosting a show while working out,
while engaging with thousands of people.
When that producer counts me down,
there's nothing but go.
(intense action music)
I grew up in an immigrant family.
My mother was a refugee from Cuba,
my father from Puerto Rico,
and they really created themselves.
My mother was an example
of a superhero for me.
She paved the way for me to say, “yeah,
“you can write your own story.”
I really am a walking
example of how you can
reframe the direction of your life.
I did not grow up an athlete.
I was the arts-and-craft kid.
I was the kid who was good at school,
and I didn't know why I felt so compelled
to physically just put one
foot in front of the other;
but I was in law school,
and one day I was like,
maybe I'll run home
instead of driving home.
For me, that unlocked powers
that I never knew I had.
I realized that when you
step into your power,
it gives people permission
to do the same thing.
So if I can be a small catalyst in that,
I damn near try every
single day on the bike.
Peloton instructors are required
to put so much energy into
every ride, into every workout.
We actually have to train
like professional athletes
to teach.
The instructor is not
just a body on a bike.
They are the conductor of an orchestra.
A lot of people don't know
that instructors spend
hours for every single playlist.
For every 30 or 45 minutes of music,
an instructor has spent hours
curating that journey.
There is an element to what we produce
that is truly a show.
There's lighting, there's
music, there's levels.
Our production department
rivals any network.
We produce 14 hours of live programming
from our studio in New York City,
and we broadcast to thousands
of bikes across the country.
Other members can see
and high-five each other
and see themselves on the leaderboard
and keeps them coming back.
We're doing something that's
never been done before,
and people are responding to it.
I received a message
from a mother who said
thank you so much for your 20-minute ride
'cause I can feel like
a badass during nap-time.
Like, I really am stronger
than I thought I was.
I was like that mic-drop, bye queen.
Do you know how amazing
it is what you just did?
I really truly approach
every ride hoping that
it plants a seed of
strength in someone's life.
I want people to leave my class
feeling like they
stepped into their power.